and during this season it's important
that we stay aware of the flu as well as
everything else i spoke with the
southwest medical doctor to learn more
take a look
welcome back dr golco thank you so much
it's great to be with you
great to see you again and of course you
know we're talking about
six season flu shots on top of the
pandemic so
who should be worried about getting a
flu shot this year absolutely you know
the flu vaccine is recommended for
everyone six months of age and older
with very few exceptions and especially
those
individuals who might be at higher risk
individuals greater than 65 years old
individuals with certain chronic medical
conditions really should be thinking
about
protecting themselves and their family
members by getting that flu shot
and how should people go about getting
their flu shot during the pandemic
that's a great question thanks to cdc
guidance and local and state ordinances
all of our facilities here at southwest
medical optimum care are
open safe and reliable for patients to
be able to come in to get their
vaccinations
and what about the the golden question
the flu vaccine
in comparison to cope at 19. that's a
great question and you know many of the
symptoms with
the flu or influenza are very similar to
covet 19.
certain key pieces that might
differentiate copic 19 symptoms
include loss of taste or smell the onset
of coping 19 can happen a lot later than
the flu
itself and it's important to remember
that the flu vaccine helps prevent
against the flu
it does not protect or prevent any
symptoms or signs
of coca-19 right and when is the right
time for people to go ahead and get
their flu shot
right now is an excellent time to get
vaccinated we know that that may change
and it changes every year depending on
the location as well as the season
and flu viruses may start to resurface
again later in
the new year but right now is a great
and optimal time to be vaccinated
okay well i hope everyone takes care and
takes your advice thank you so much dr
gokul
it's a pleasure stay safe me too
southwest medical has locations across
southern nevada for more information
call that number
right there on your screen or just visit
smalv.com
we'll be right back